- Rolling up to JFK,
feeling pretty good.
Head to Detroit.
Quick keynote for
Dan Gilbert and his whole
family of businesses.
Owner of the Cavs, Quicken,
a bunch of other businesses,
amazing American entrepreneur.
Quickly back to the airport,
headed to London.
Seven, eight
hours of London meetings
for Vayner London, then boom.
Right on a plane
to Hamburg, Germany.
Quick shower.
Right into the
speaker's dinner that night.
Get some sleep,
give a keynote,
flip it right back to NYC.
That's how I do it.
("Dreams Worth
Dying For" by Hi-Rez)
I think everything
stems from the top.
I think they feel at home
because I feel like I'm parent
and I think all my actions
between the room they live in
and the psychology I deploy
and the listening
and the talking,
You know, I think
people only feel at home
when the parents
make it feel at home.
I think it's the
job of every CEO.
Yes, businesses can
actually start giving a fuck
about people instead of
how much money they make,
because a funny
thing happens when
you give a fuck about people.
You end up making more money.
I mean I don't
think it's unfortunate
those companies should
then make what is appropriate
and all the
people that work there,
they're more than welcome
to start their own company
or work somewhere else.
You know this whole narrative of
like these businesses are shit.
Yes, do I want businesses
to care about people more?
Yes, it feels nice
and it feels right
and it's a legacy I wanna leave,
and I think it'll actually
make them more money,
but the
employees aren't being,
you know this is not slavery.
Everybody has to be accountable.
This isn't just
the man's fucked up
or the business is fucked up.
The employees fucked up if
they're in a shit situation.
Instead of going
home at five o'clock
and drinking
beer and complaining,
go on fucking job listings,
interviews, networks.
Find a different fucking job.
The good cafeteria,
the free granola,
I just think that's horse shit.
Those are tactics
that bullshit companies do
to try to make people...
The people are
inspired and feeling good
because they feel safe
and they can feel
like they can grow.
They feel like safe and
they feel like they can grow.
That's the shit that matters,
not fucking free
cheerios on fucking Tuesday.
And you guys have to hound me
until you get this out of me,
which is with you guys
and the SVP of the business
and I'm probably gonna start
bringing you guys to them,
one of you,
so that it's even faster.
I think that a lot of
times it'll be the first time
like the guy (censored)
wouldn't have brought you to.
You know what I mean?
Your job is to not
let me off the hook
after I have a
senior client meeting.
Or like inspiration.
I like putting up
signs and I do that shit
but I don't think at
Vayner are happy and killing it
because I have a
picture of me saying
your funeral matters.
That's up there
because I like that,
not because
that's there as a tactic.
It's all religion.
They have to feel safe and
they have to feel
like they can grow.
You know and that's it.
You're not gonna trick people
by having 24 hour massages
in a fucking room,
you know what I mean?
Band-aids,
everybody's got band-aids.
Nobody gives a fuck
about your hardwood floor
or the soda fountain machine.
They're nice
and we have them
but I'm not the one
who's ever making that happen.
That's other people
in my company
that decide those things.
I have no interest in band-aids.
Shit works
because I give a fuck.
- Always shit talking.
- This is the man right here.
- You seem like you're sleeping.
- They're the best thing--
- They look crazy.
They're the best thing
since the actual phone.
- They look crazy
as a mother fucker.
- Alright Nate, I gotta go,
I got a friend here.
See you, love you, bye.
- So you just
filmed him the whole time?
- [DRock] Yep.
- Steve, honestly
on a very serious note,
this is what you should do.
- What movie is that?
- "Truman Show," "Truman Show."
You should do this.
You know what's
great about this?
You don't have to do anything.
You don't fucking do anything.
- This guy's
running the whole time.
- Yeah, yeah, and that's weird
and it takes a few
minutes to like get that.
- It's really weird.
- But it's getting
way less weird.
How many meetings have
we been in where now that's
two people doing.
It's a foregone conclusion.
- Brand meetings?
- Very rare.
Never, by the way
some clients want me to.
- That's crazy, man.
- I mean very rarely, and we'd
never put anything that's...
There's never been...
I mean I have to....
The only downside is
that I have to watch it
because I might
say something that.
- Of course, how could you
control, I can't control it.
I'm gonna say something that--
- You're the editor.
- A secret, a trade secrets.
- [Gary] No no, it's what I do.
I watch it and you know after
awhile the team kinda knows,
but you still gotta like
you know you're saying
something that's subtle.
DRock, can you email
Alex De Simone
Zak, Nadler and Tyler
and tell them I'm
really into fireside chats
'cause it makes
me do new stuff?
- We just have two
silly questions for you.
We need your arch nemesis
and your proudest mission.
- Tom Brady.
- Okay.
- And Michael Jordan,
I'm putting two.
- Okay, proudest mission?
- Proudest mission is
becoming the
foundation of my family.
- Cool.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
"Like We Own This Place"
by Ryan Caraveo)
- DRock, you had this filming.
I'm so proud of you.
- [DRock] I know right.
I knew you were going to try
and do something like that.
- You're so funny.
I literally went Instagram
Live because you walked away
and I wanted you to feel bad
and meanwhile guys,
don't touch anything.
DRock did it,
he left his camera
right here the whole time.
- [DRock] I'm trying.
- And, he knows me,
he knows me so well.
This is how fucked up I am,
DRock goes to take a piss,
or I don't know what
the hell you just did.
Piss?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Great and I'm like you
know what I'm going to go
on Instagram live
and he's gonna come back
and be really sad
that he missed out
on like 10 minutes of footage.
Unbelievable.
Anyway, thank
you all for the love.
Sergei good to see you.
Angel good to see you.
How do I develop
my level of patience?
BCNTX5, brother
there's just no other way
other than just doing it, right.
DRock, you feel like you've
gained patience with me?
- [DRock] A lot, a lot.
- Let's interview DRock.
That'd be a good idea.
DRock, let's flip the switch.
- [DRock] When you're patient,
and you don't want anything,
you don't need
anything from anyone,
you treat everybody--
- The same.
- [DRock] Exactly.
- That makes sense right?
Because whether
you're the owner of the Cavs,
who I'm about to
go on stage with,
or you're a Cavs
fan in the last row,
I'm actually in zero
need of either of them.
- [DRock] And, you just became
personal with all of them.
- You like that?
- [DRock] You have
different techniques--
- Well, there's
different topics.
- [DRock] Topics,
right, but I love that.
- Think, I'm
fucking not anything yet.
I haven't done anything yet.
- [DRock] Exactly and
even the people around you--
- They know that,
they know that, right?
Everyday we're like,
"Wait 'til they see
six months from now,
"wait 'til they see
"wait 'til they..."
Yo.
- [DRock] Patience
is very important.
- This new hoodie is legit.
Garyveeshop.com
And then I've got
the book in January
and the VaynerMedia thing.
I don't know how
many of you were part
of the live stream last
night, but this was awesome.
I came up with a new business,
and I've been thinking about it,
but Zappos and
Disney sell tours.
So, we're gonna do
that at VaynerMedia.
It's gonna be programmed,
paid media, video production.
I'm also, you
didn't see this email,
I'm also gonna film it.
- [DRock] The whole thing.
- And all ten people
are gonna do an interview
of six questions I come up with
and we're gonna give
them a piece of content
to leave with, kind of on the
manifesto of how do you start.
- [DRock] I love that.
- Fucking awesome, right?
That's worth the ten,
I'm trying to figure out
how people are like,
holy fuck, for $10,000.
Yeah, like, if you can
make something worth $50.
- [DRock] That and
the keynote.
- That's it, that's it,
and the keynotes
are gonna be like,
Ashton Kutcher,
Tony Robbins, fucking,
like, you know,
Ferriss, Kevin Rowe.
It's gonna,
people are gonna shit.
Of course, this is the whole
day, 11 hours, immersive,
and then you're gonna
make connections, too.
So think about the
like-minded people,
then you're there and be like,
"Hey you wanna
go out to dinner?"
We're gonna send--
Me and Nate came
up with some shit.
We're gonna send people
to certain dinner spots,
where they're
gonna get hooked up.
Hunt and Fish Club,
places where I go.
So, like, randomly
I'll be there too.
And we've got some
ideas, like swag packs
and basically how do we
make it worth $100 for $10.
Anyway, if your interested to
be part of the first groups.
It will be remarkable, be
the best day you ever spend.
It could change
your game forever.
Very focused, detail shit.
Not the motivation
stuff, that's for free.
Details, this is how
we execute paid campaigns,
this is how you should
be thinking about video,
this is how you
should be thinking about...
VaynerTalent,
like, fucking real.
And then I'll come
in and answer questions
for this group, obviously.
Small business team,
video production,
account strategy,
global strategy.
How you do the ads,
how you make the videos.
Designers, art, how
we brainstorm ideas.
It's gonna be fucking huge.
Alright.
It's just about starting.
So many of you are
stuck and can't start.
So, I've actually for
the first time in my career,
like literally, not
for the first time, but...
You never see me do
this, DRock, right?
Like literally send you guys
a text of what I want to make.
It's just not how
I usually do stuff,
but it's so important to me
that I broke it down
into the what, how, and where.
Like what, everyone of
you that has not started
your business or
started your personal brand
or building your influence,
you need to make something,
and that thing is a manifesto.
There's this
classic video I made
back in the day while
I was on a London flight
that was just kinda
like my thoughts that day.
It wasn't kinda like episode 101
of a recap or
anything like that.
It was just my thoughts of
where I was at at that moment.
I was kinda
talking shit, actually.
It's gonna be fun to look
back at that, DRock, right?
I was kinda like, "You
guys don't know", right?
It's gonna be cool, actually.
Anyway, nonetheless.
They just don't know me.
They don't understand
what I'm going to do.
They don't
understand that it's early.
People just don't
understand how early it is.
I'm 36. I'm a kid.
Every one of you
needs to sit down
and make a piece
of content, whether,
and this is now the how,
whether this is video form,
whether this is audio form,
or whether this is
written form, right?
Audio being a podcast, right?
Heck, you don't even
have to do a podcast,
put the record on your phone
and just speak your truth.
Get in front of a
camera, selfie style,
or set it up on a tripod,
or have a DRock,
your nephew, your sister,
your aunt, your daughter,
I don't care, or you write it.
The way all of
you need to do this
and how you
actually start is by doing.
So, first you start.
What are you gonna talk about?
I've broken that down for you.
I've fixed it
for you, here it is.
Tell the world, what's up.
Either how
you're feeling right now
and or what you're about to do.
That's it.
I'm done giving you guys
the top line strategy.
I'm gonna go
detailed for you today.
This is it.
This is how you start.
I'm going to help you right now.
Either tell people how you're
feeling exactly right now
and what you're
thinking about yourself,
about the world,
about the state of
the union of coffee,
or tell me what
you're gonna do, right?
Tell me, I know
I say fuck you're gonna,
but you need to
put it out there.
You're stuck, you haven't
started because you're stuck.
So here you go.
What, what are you
going to talk about,
what do you
want to be known for?
You want to be in
health and fitness,
you want to be in strategy,
you want to be in social media,
you want to be in sneakers,
you want to be in coffee,
you want to be in electronics,
you want to be in fashion,
I don't care.
- [Dan Gilbert] What do
you care about number one?
- Meritocracy.
- First you said wait,
you love dictatorship.
- Yes.
- Now you love
meritocracy, which is it?
- Correct, both.
- How can it be both?
- Easy when you're
pulling from both sides you win.
The contradictions are
where all the magic is.
You want to be
successful and go fast?
Don't give a fuck about what
anybody thinks about you.
You want to go fast and win?
Care about what every
single person says about you.
Yeah.
Empathy matters as much as ego.
It's the balance of the
opposite things that allows
the winners to really win.
- I'm trying to
know who I am right now.
(laughing)
("Lights Go Down" By Bazanji)
- And you want to leave a
legacy of a positive picture?
- [Gary] I dictate,
the 10 percent that
matters to me the most.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm a dictator,
on the 10 percent that
matters to me the most
and then open for
everybody on the 90 percent
and then reward the
people that are winning.
- Question about short form
and long form content.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I'm hearing a lot
that YouTube and Facebook
is really into
long form content.
- [Gary] Every content--
- Did it change overnight?
- No, remember how I said
headline readers
versus practitioners?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] The headline
sounds right,
like do it fast, make it short.
- Right.
- [Gary] Sure or if a three
hour movie is awesome
people will sit and watch it.
It's just completely
based on the content.
- I'm so happy to hear
this because I do long form
and I want to
have you on my site,
it's called A Drink With.
- Okay.
- We just had a drink with Dan.
- I love it.
- And it is a little bit
longer and then like--
- [Gary] If it's good,
people will watch.
- You talk
about fear, ladder up.
- [Gary] Yes.
- So how do you push
through that, those ladders.
- By talking to them.
Communication is,
communication is the only thing
that solves anything ever.
You enjoyed that?
- It was so funny.
The best part was at the end,
I know you like, you
get up and do your thing.
- Yeah.
- And I like see the two chairs,
Dan's gonna try to interview him?
That's going to go great.
It was unbelievable,
that was the best.
(laughing)
- That was a lot of fun yes.
What gets people hired?
- Hired or just it's like what--
- Doing, what will
separate you is doing.
- Okay.
- Actually making content,
like actually doing.
- Okay.
- Like when you walk in
and this is how
I built my Instagram,
or this is how I thought
about pre-roll on Facebook,
or this is how
I made a long form vid,
like if you actually can,
like I designed
these filters on Snapchat.
- Okay.
- Doing.
- That kind of stuff.
- Yes.
- Okay, cause I'm,
I don't have a
company here,
I just invited by Dan
but I'm like this is great.
- Doing.
- Like this is
an experience, so.
- Doing is always the answer.
- [Woman] Alright.
- Awesome, yeah
nice to meet you.
- Later bro.
- We'll talk soon?
- Yeah.
- Good man.
Alright.
- I had a question.
- Yep.
- I just wanted to
say nice to meet ya,
I just wanted to
try and grab a picture.
- Yeah let's do it, let's do it,
he's kind of waiting around,
I'm gonna like
miss my fucking flight.
("Lights Go Down" By Bazanji)
I feel like in 20
years when I have that thing.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Gary] And the me
coming up does it,
everybody will
respond well to it
because it's that
pure form of it.
I'm trying to figure
out how big of an impact
I can have at this
kind of budget level.
Which will then give me
leverage to buy businesses,
you know I'm in a place
right now with my career,
where I'm getting,
the kind of emails
I get are so strange.
Entrepreneurs are funny now,
they're like I'll give
you 40 percent of my business
to be my partner
(woman laughing)
and we're doing seven figures,
I'm like this is
getting weird, like.
Take care, stay well.
Is that what he said?
That's bad, we
might miss the flight.
This is as about as
late as we've pushed it.
Fuck.
We miss this flight,
I'm not going to London.
That's my gut.
- [DRock] Thank you.
- [Woman 2] You're welcome,
you guys can just
stand right over there.
She'll take care, okay?
- [Woman 3] What
are you guys up to?
- [DRock] What are we up to?
- [Gary] In life?
- [DRock] In life?
- [Gary] I'm trying to buy
the New York Jets.
That's me.